hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
for my Game of Thrones bonus video I
promise I do something a little more
bookish because you guys wanted to jump
into theories and prophecies so this is
going to be all about the White Walkers
not being evil
you know the premise being the White
Walkers are not just like straight-up
villains in order to walk you through
this I'm gonna have to talk a lot about
theories of what's going to happen in
the next two books as well as the show
so none of this is stuff that has
already happened so technically I don't
consider it spoilers but just in case
strong spoiler warning for mega
earth-shattering theories of Ice and
Fire and real quick shout out to Jessie
wait you're the first winner of my
weekly book giveaway you basically get
to pick any of George RR Martin's books
but I'll be messaging you on your
channel for details round 2 of the
giveaway starts right now so all you
have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so I'll announce the winner next
week whenever I post my next game of
Thrones bonus video so my theory about
White Walkers not being evil depends a
lot on context if you've only seen the
show it's a lot harder to defend so
that's why it helps to read the books
you know there's much better context for
the characters and one thing the show
hasn't dealt with a lot is the idea of
unreliable narration and history being
falsified even the way White Walkers
look on the show has been very very
different from the way they're portrayed
in the books in the books they have what
is described as an otherworldly beauty
on the show they look more like frozen
versions of the colossal Titan from
attack on Titan you know very ugly so
let's start with the idea that things
that we've learned about the White
Walkers and other magical creatures on
the show and in the books is false for
example during the princess in the Queen
short story maesters play a big role and
it's a plight that they had a grand
conspiracy to get rid of the Targaryen
dragons you know by exacerbating the
Targaryen Civil War and poisoning the
remaining targetting dragons that lived
on masers are largely responsible for
writing down history and giving counsel
to rulers they're also the scientists of
Westeros you know as such they hate
magic
for a lot of the same reasons as Varys
it's something they don't fully
understand and cannot control so just
that a little bit more complicated you
know you have the White Walkers and the
great other and you have the red God and
his followers but then you have like the
maesters in the middle that are just
falsifying stuff about all these people
quick sidenote - I think there are way
more than three factions but for the
sake of simplicity I'm just using the
maesters as one example of a faction
that's falsifying history so fire and
ice exist in a state of balance you know
how do you tip that balance
well you basically get rid of magic one
way to do that is by getting rid of
dragons just because they have an innate
connection to magic so if most of what
the maesters has written about dragons
is false that means there's a strong
chance the history about other magical
events and races has been falsified you
know like White Walkers and children of
the forest you know add to that that
most of the written history of the last
time we saw the White Walkers during the
long night wasn't recorded till hundreds
of years after it ended but how do we
find out that the maesters have been
falsifying history about you know these
magical events mostly when characters
point out contradictions in books inside
the show I know it's funny to read about
characters reading the only characters
we've seen so far that have called out
historical Texas false are Samwell
talking about Scrolls in the Nights
Watch and Tyrion talking about books
written about dragons at the Citadel in
King's Landing so let's roll with the
premise that Fire and Ice are just two
diametric opposite you know there's just
two states that exist in a balance you
know White Walkers being on one side
dragons in the red God being on the
other
I'm just aligning dragons with the red
God in lieu of fire magic
it hasn't been expressed literally in
the books on the show but a creature
born of fire is probably tangentially
related to the red God so most of the
history that we've learned about the
White Walkers has actually been passed
down orally via like old man
tormund Giantsbane mance rayder you know
people in the north in old man's story
she talks about how the long night came
brought the White Walkers they battled
the combined forces of the first men and
the children of the force for a long
time then the last hero came with his
dragons steel blade and the war ended I
think the Dragons steel is just a
reference for Valyrian steel but then
after all that the wall was built so we
really don't know a lot about the last
hero but I think he's just the
personification of his aura high if he
used a Valyrian steel blade it means he
either came from that region of Essos
and had dragons or he knew someone who
had those things it stands the reason
that you know if you had Valyrian steel
you came from a period in time when the
Valyrians had tamed dragons
currently we don't really have a date
for whenever Valyrian first learned to
do that we only know when the doom
happened the wall for example was built
over 8,000 years ago and that only came
at the end of the long night so it is
really hard to place history and the
maesters didn't even start recording all
that history till hundreds of years
after it happened so you see how the
problem gets started with people passing
down false accounts of history but we do
have this idea of Fire and Ice you know
with Azure
hi dragons flurry and steel and white
walkers on the other side and the
interesting thing about old Nan's tales
are that they only speak of the White
Walkers closing in around the last hero
she never talks about him killing them
all and how do you end a war without
killing the other side you broker a
peace treaty you know otherwise how
would there still be White Walkers that
have survived to today
there hasn't been any evidence of a
black portal to Hell or any other
dimensional gates or anything crazy like
that so some of them would have had to
survive the long night and retreat to
the lands of always winter if the last
hero only appeared at the end of the
long night you know what if he was just
someone to broker that peace treaty you
know he wasn't just like a simple
warrior or general the children of the
forest had their own war with the first
men and if they eventually brokered
their own peace with them it's not so
hard to believe that a peace treaty
could be made with another supernatural
force so jumping forward in time to
modern day Westeros how do you seal a
peace treaty between two houses with a
marriage who do we know in game thrones
history that took a white Walker as a
bride the night's king he's another
mythical figure that we have believed to
be evil based on what we've seen so far
but it's not so hard to believe that his
history was also falsified in the books
bran has talked about old man telling
him stories of how the night's king was
basically a stark of Winterfell who
lived after the wall was built I know
the timeline gets a little fuzzy there
you know previously it was believed the
night's king was formerly the 13th Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch he was a
stark you know not the true heir of
Winterfell but it's not so hard to
believe that the night's king was really
just the fulfillment of the terms of the
peace treaty between the White Walkers
and the forces of men and here's where
we need to talk about the wall because
it's just a huge point of interest in
the end of the long night as well as on
the show right now there are a couple
theories about how it got built but one
says that it happens slowly over the
centuries using a combination of
large-scale manpower and magic but what
about this theory the White Walkers
built the wall using their ice magic and
they built it to seal off men from their
lands it's not so hard to believe that
over time people could have forgotten
what the true purpose of the wall is
people in the south in the last couple
centuries have started to think of it is
more of a thing to keep the wildlings
out of the south as opposed to you know
keep them away from the White Walkers so
the idea is that over time myths about
the creation of the wall and the night's
king could have been twisted there's
also a lot of stories about stark
periodically interbreeding with people
in the north so there is precedent for
stark intermarrying with someone else
you know like a white Walker bride I
know we haven't seen any female white
walkers yet but that doesn't mean that
none have existed I mean historically
the Knights Queen did exist like she was
a figure we just don't know a lot about
her so real quick heads up because the
rest of my theory involves characters on
the show right now and future events I'm
gonna say spoiler warning one more time
everybody ready okay so the interesting
thing about this is that it would imply
that the Starks have white Walker DNA
floating in their veins
they are the human personification of
winter winter Brinks ice white walkers
are based on ice magic that means that
in whatever final battle happens in the
next two books the Starks or the
surviving starts you know Jon Snow for
example would align themselves with the
white walkers crazy I know I have also
seen theories about the three-eyed Raven
or Brynden rivers however you want to
think about him being a servant of the
great other and if bran Stark is going
to replace him it just means one more
stark aligning himself with the forces
of winter who's the fire in this
scenario though the other side well
Melisandre obviously but also Daenerys
and her dragons they're the
personification of fire you know House
Targaryen 'he's motto is fire and blood
so let's time travel back to present-day
why did the White Walkers wait till just
now to start attacking again it's
possible that the only reason they're
taking action is because men are not
upholding the peace treaty you have
wildlings colonizing in the north and
the beginnings of the white walk our
texts coincide with the re-emergence of
dragons you know Fire and Ice it's like
the cosmic balance has to be maintained
so as fire comes back so does ice and so
here's where we need to talk about the
azure Ahai prophecy you know the prince
who was promised Rhaegar Targaryen was
obsessed with the prophecy what if he
understood that balance must be
maintained and that's why he had a child
with Lyanna stark to bond ice to fire
that's another theory that we won't get
more information about until book six is
released but it would mean that Jon Snow
is the culmination of the prophecy like
he's the new version of the last hero in
the night's king I think those two
people are actually the same person
although it's possible that they're
separate people and here's something
really interesting if the Starks really
are connected to the white walk
then it's fun to think about their
reemergence being the results of so many
Starks being killed
it makes winter is coming sound more
like a battle cry than a fearful
premonition but either way I think that
John and Daenerys are going to be two
sides of this equation which means they
have to exist in opposition meaning that
depending on whose perspective you take
when is the hero and one is the villain
so think about the idea that Daenerys is
ultimately going to become the villain
of the series I know it's totally just a
theory but whenever you look for
evidence in Rhaegar prophecies like the
bit about the blue flower growing in the
wall of ice you start to see how John
could really be the prince who is
promised so once all this sinks in let
me know what all your white Walker
theories are in the comments below do
you think they're really evil or are
they just another opposing force to
balance out you know dragons the red God
and Daenerys so my next bonus video is
going to post next week on Sunday be
sure to subscribe to get it because I'm
a little bit behind and because mondays
are Teen Wolf now I'm not going to do a
Q&A for this video so I'll just try to
answer as many questions in the comments
below right now click here to learn more
about Aegon the Conqueror and click here
to get all my season 5 theories
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow high fives
you